[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein kleines basic video und
zwar beides plunder teig zubereiten
plunder teig das ist so eine art
blätterteig aber mit etwas hilfe drin
ihr kennt unser tag wahrscheinlich auch
zum beispiel von croissants von einem
schoko croissants der ist wirklich schön
locker und fluffig will ich eigentlich
sagen aber im prinzip ist der teig hat
nämlich mehrere schichten und die
schichten kommen durch die butter
zustande und blutet kann man auch fertig
kaufen aber ich kaufe den nicht gerne
denn mittlerweile werden einfach wie
oftmals wird butter durch zum beispiel
polen versetzt
und ich finde gerade die butter macht er
diesen tollen geschmack aus deswegen
machen wir denn heute selber aber heute
gibt eine einfache variante denn
normalerweise muss man ganz viele touren
machen mit so einem butter block und es
ist natürlich ziemlich aufwendig aber je
nachdem was ich machen möchte kann man
kann ich eben auch diese vereinfachte
variante verwenden und die einfache
variante ist wirklich super einfach
system statt mit den zutaten also ich
brauche den klondike 500 gramm mehl ein
päckchen trockenhefe zwei teelöffel salz
zwei teelöffel zucker 300 gramm kalte
butter 130 mm wasser und 120 mm mild die
zutaten müssen alle ganz kalt sein das
ist ganz wichtig jetzt gebe ich zuerst
einmal die trockenen zutaten uns eine
küchenmaschine das mache ich jetzt hier
oben im mixer ihr könnt es ganz
natürlich auch mit den händen zu
bereiten oder mit dem messer aber da
müsste einfach darauf achten dass der
teig nicht weich wird und nicht warm
wird
kommt da noch zucker und salz mit dazu
die trockenen zutaten die
verbindlichkeiten mal kurz
jetzt gebe ich die kalte butter noch mit
rein die habe ich schon in stücke
geschnitten und jetzt ist gleich ganz
wichtig dass diese masse nur noch so
lange verbunden hier bis ich noch so
kleine butter stücke mit drin habe und
diese kleinen butter stücke die sorgen
später dann dafür dass der teig eben
richtig schön in einzelnen schichten
aufgeht
[Musik]
am besten immer mal wieder kontrollieren
wenn die ganz großen stücke weg sind so
sieht der teig hier jetzt aus das heißt
hier überall noch diese kleinen feinen
butter stücke die sind auch noch schön
kalt
jetzt nehme ich eine schüssel und gebt
da die zwei flüssigkeiten rein also
milch und wasser
da kommt der teil gibt es dazu und die
zutaten verbinde ich jetzt mit einem
back löffel
hat nur soweit also setzt kein
zusammenhängen der teig ergeben
und falls er wie gesagt nicht so einen
mixer habt könnt ihr den teig ja auch
mit dem hinten zu bereiten und da würde
jedem am besten so der hacker nehmen das
ist ein teil zur hacke und da wir der
teig einfach nicht weich und nicht warm
und den nehme ich zum beispiel auch
gerne für den mürbeteig der teig fertig
jetzt brauche ich ein stück
frischhaltefolie raus und fülle den tag
raus
[Musik]
und jetzt packe ich den so ein dass er
jetzt schon rechteckig wird das heißt
ich drücke hier die folie einfach
zurecht
[Musik]
und damit er auf der einen seite nicht
wieder aufgeht habe ich die seite auch
noch ein
und das ist jetzt so der grundstein der
muss jetzt nochmals zwei stunden durch
gekühlt werden
und ihr könnt denen auch zum beispiel am
tag vorher schon mal zu bereiten
jetzt ist der teig gut durchgeführt und
jetzt sieht man auch ganz schön diese
kleinen kleinen butter stückchen die
zweite ich ihnen auf einer bemehlten
arbeitsfläche die sollte jetzt auch gut
gemeint seien damit die butter nicht
klebt werde ich ihn auf 30 mal 20
zentimeter größe ausholen
[Musik]
das überschüssige mail dann immer wieder
wegfuhren
und jetzt glaube ich den teig so
zusammen dass er gedrittelt wird und
jetzt einmal drehen
und jetzt hat der teig die maße 10 mal
und jetzt werde ich eben der länge nach
auf rollen auf etwa 920 das heißt ich
rolle es hier
den teig einfach länger
[Musik]
jetzt hat der teig etwa die maße 90 x 20
jetzt drittel ich ihn wieder
jetzt legen wieder drei teigschichten
übereinander
jetzt soll ich ihnen so wieder auf 90 cm
länge aus und ihr seht dadurch dass ich
den teig dann immer wieder falsche aus
rolle wieder fallen aus halle entstehen
so die einzelnen dünnen schichten und da
ist jetzt nur ganz wichtig dass der teig
nicht warm wird das heißt falls ihr das
gefühl habe die butter wird waren sie
schmilzt dann tut man den teig kurz in
den kühlschrank und arbeiten an danach
wieder weiter
[Musik]
dieses mal wieder teig nicht gedrittelt
sondern ich lege die beiden äußeren
teile bis zur mitte und falte sie dann
zusammen so wie ein buch
[Musik]
so lege ich jetzt den teig wieder in die
folie hinein
die folie habe ich auch aufgehoben sie
muss man nicht verschwenden und
wegschmeißen und packen jetzt wieder gut
ein und muss ihnen dann im kühlschrank
erneut kühlen lassen und zwar für etwa
zwei bis vier stunden
[Musik]
der einfache plünderei ist jetzt fertig
durch gekühlt und den werde ich jetzt
gleich auf fünf millimeter starke
aufräumen und kann dann wirklich alles
zubereiten muss ich möchte die fans
gleich benutzen um ein wie vor linken
zuzubereiten da verlinkt ich euch das
video auch in der infobox und ihr könnt
es natürlich auch benutzen um was süßes
zu machen wie zum beispiel croissants
oder plundergebäck oder platz zum
beispiel also die mischung aus donath
und croissant kroner celica habe ich
auch schon auf seinem kanal ein video
dazu jedenfalls könnte den teig jetzt
auch einfrieren
auch nachdem rollen einfrieren als im
prinzip ab jetzt so den teig hergestellt
und die menge ist auch wirklich sehr
viel fast ein kilo teig und den könnt
ihr auch wirklich einfach einfrieren und
zu hab da immer mal wieder plunder teig
auf vorrat und falls ihr dieses rezept
sucht dann könnte es gerne auch salehs
mit flock de nachlesen und nachmachen
und falls ihr natürlich auch an dem
original interessiert seid also an der
traditionellen variante mit dem butter
block dann mache ich das auch ganz gerne
und auch gern auch mal in blätterteig
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal bis danzig
[Musik]